[Musique]
j'ai besoin d'accéder aux maladies
megasol halloween l'humain est souvent
différent de l'impression qu'il donne à
première vue
ça
pour
monstre une fille trop bizarre depuis
que j'ai touché cette saloperie de trucs
bleus
je peux me rendre accessible
[Musique]
mr horrible en ce moment
avec l'ère obama
moment été enlevés jeudi je t'en prie
pas paxton croire et si je peux monde
invisible
ils sont sûrement par là quelque part
bouclé toutes les issues
on voit d'abord trouver qui a enlevé ma
mère je suis tu es un homme
enfin je veux dire tout beau tout me
voici à apt oubliée ap
comme application ouais ça fait de toi
un vrai super héros
je vous écoute
à toi tu n'es amusez vous bien